hi mystery recapped here today I am
going to explain a Chinese language
action comedy film called Kung Fu dunk
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a homeless man sleeping near a dumping
site is woken up by the noise of a
baby's cry he registers that someone is
abandoned their month's old infant in
the dumpster he wants to help the child
but can hardly take care of himself so
instead he brings the kid to a kung fu
school the master opens a book about
Kung Fu that was found with the baby he
decides that the kid is going to be a
great Kung Fu Master in the future and
accepts him as a disciple fast forward
five years later little Fang XI ji knows
everything about Kung Fu as it is the
only thing he was taught since he
learned to walk the master treats him as
his own son which is why he is sad about
the decision he is about to make one
night he tells Fang that if someone
learns the art of kung fu sincerely they
can eventually learn to turn back time
he claims that he has fulfilled his
purpose in life and hopes that Fang will
do the same with that being said he
freezes himself to death using an
ancient Kung Fu technique damn I
shouldn't have quit karate Fang can
hardly understand what is going on he
runs to the Master's dead body asking
him to come back to life that day he
learns a valuable lesson about life and
death cut to several years later Fang is
now a young man still working in the
Kung Fu school but after his master's
death his life hasn't been easy he is
treated as a punching bag by the new
Masters to teach the students of the
school because he is an orphan no one
respects or loves him Fang takes all the
abuse he faces thinking that he is
indebted to the Kung Fu school one
morning the Headmaster calls Fang to the
field to perform a new technique on him
this time Fang wears a Shaolin iron vest
under his clothes to not feel the
principal's punches but when he is
caught the man denies him food and kicks
him out for the night with nowhere to go
Fang comes by the river and throws cans
into a bin to pass time he doesn't miss
a single shot which is surprising to an
old man watching him named Wang Lee the
man thinks it must be easy and tries to
throw in himself only then does he
realize that Fang must have practiced
for years to be that precise when Wang
Lee finds out that Fang is hungry he
presents him with an offer if Fang can
land a coin inside the old man's mouth
from a distance he promises to treat him
to a meal Fang does so with zero effort
surprising Wang Lee even more he then
takes the kid to an expensive five-star
restaurant that is way out of Fang's
budget but it turns out that Wang Lee's
daughter works in the kitchen and can
manage to bring food for both of them
they enjoy the meal together at the back
of the restaurant later the two go to a
casino and play darts Fang lands every
shot with Precision which makes the
owner think they are cheating the
manager of the casino brother who tries
to kick them out unaware that Fang is a
trained black belt in kung fu a fight
ensues where Fang easily defeats all of
whose Men by the end of the fight the
casino is in shambles to take revenge
for the loss the sadistic owner of the
club Wang seriously two wangs in this
movie finds out everything about Fang
and goes to the Kung Fu school he pays
the principal a large sum of money and
buys the entire place then Fang is
brought in front of everyone and asked
to take a beating because he cannot go
against the principal's orders he takes
the abuse for as long as he can even
after that he is kicked out of the
school in the evening Fang goes to meet
Wang Lee again and tells him everything
that happened Wang Lee has planned
something for Fang and asks him if he
can play basketball although skeptical
Fang is desperate to do anything to earn
money he tests his skills by throwing a
ball to the bin several meters away with
pinpoint accuracy Wang Lee pulls some
strings and arranges a meeting with the
dean of a college whose basketball team
is in need of a good player the dean
agrees to take Fang in and organizes a
press conference the next day being the
center of attention is strange to Fang
but he is happy that he is being
welcomed into a new organization
suddenly a girl named Lily objects to
his admission she is the sister of the
team captain Ting Wei and wants him to
approve Fang before he is taken into the
team Ting Wei is a star player but an
alcoholic even while drunk he makes a
slam dunk and proves his skills Fang has
given a ball and asked to do the same he
throws it from several meters away and
scores after his potential has been
tested he is officially taken into the
team that evening fangos to his first
practice but feels like nobody's happy
to have him on the team after practice
he finds tang in the car drinking in
broad daylight Fang assumes the captain
is mad at him and asks him to beat him
to let go of his anger he thinks it's a
plausible way to release anger because
the principal used to do the same Ting
however thinks the idea is absurd they
talk for a while and discover many
similarities the following day Ting
comes to practice early something he
doesn't do usually talking to Fang
yesterday has resurfaced his suppressed
passion to win Lilly can almost not
believe that her brother is early for
once then we are introduced to the best
player on the team Lan Lily has a huge
crush on him but has always pushed aside
since Lan has many followers she
introduces him to Fang and the players
share a brief chat in the following
scene their team is playing the first
match of a championship since Fang is a
new player he is made to stay on the
sidelines for the first half of the game
the team does average eventually Ting is
tired and hurt Wang Lee insists they let
Fang replace him for the last few
minutes of the game Fang gets to play
but unlike what everyone had thought he
delivers the worst performance the team
is about to lose because of his
sloppiness until he scores a final
basket and turns the game around they
win the game but Fang registers that he
has to practice harder to be as good as
the other players starting that day he
trains with his teammates during the day
and chains himself to a running bus at
night to increase his stamina Lily
always cheers for him during practice
and supports him dearly slowly Fang
starts falling for her he waits for her
outside her house for hours sending her
funny pictures of himself and puts a lot
of effort into impressing her after a
month of training Fang goes to Tang
wanting to learn how to slam dunk
however Ting thinks he should learn to
walk first before he begins running at
night when no one is around Fang
practices slam dunks but hurts himself
in the process the following day is the
quarterfinals of the championship before
the game the captain of the opposite
team makes fun of fang for being an
orphan the game begins and instantly
falls on their side they score basket
after basket most of which are assisted
or scored by Fang everything goes well
until he tries to score a slam dunk but
instead slams himself into the basket
still the team wins the game all the
matches that follow are also won by Fang
and the team he becomes the new Rising
player and the Talk of the Town one
night the team goes to a club to
celebrate when Fang is alone a guy from
another basketball team named Lee a
approaches him according to Lee Fang is
wasting his potential by being on the
wrong team he wants Fang to join the
team of Fireball University after
offering him a business card Lee goes to
meet his sponsor who happens to be the
owner of the casino Wang it turns out
that Lee used to be Ting's best friend
and teammate but he betrayed their team
a day before the finals and joined the
fireball University because of Wang this
caused their team to lose the last
tournament which in turn made Ting an
alcoholic the fireball University is
famous for stealing good players from
other universities for their own good
that is why they want Fang so
desperately Lily is scared that Fang
will also leave the team like Lee but he
assures her that he is no LeBron James
and he will not leave just to win it is
then the day of the final match between
Fang's team and the fireball University
the opponents did not play fairly and
injure most of Fang's teammates the
referee has also been corrupted by Wang
hence no action is taken against the
team the captain and Lan have to be sent
to the sidelines because of their
injuries still fangs single-handedly
gives the opponents a hard competition
he uses his knowledge of kung fu to use
the opposition's game plan against them
by now the fireball is leading 18-2
suddenly someone cuts the power supply
to the arena causing the game to be
postponed in the following scene Wang
Lee and Fang are together outside the
university Fang feels like his parents
were in the arena during the last match
but doesn't have a way to confirm his
suspicion just then the manager of the
casino brother who approaches them it
turns out he got into an argument with
the owner Wang and wants to teach him a
lesson he was the one who cut the power
supply in the last game he bets 5
million Yuan on Fang and urges him to
win the next half of the game however
since most of his teammates are injured
they are at a loss the teachers from the
Kung Fu School come to visit Fang
wishing him luck he asks them to join
the team team but since their school is
owned by Wang they cannot go against him
in the following scene we see the star
player Lan and Lily together Lily
confesses her feelings to him but Lan
says he is still in love with his late
girlfriend when she is heartbroken Fang
stays by her side and Promises to always
be there for her then the day of the
final game arrives Feng has no hope of
recovering in the game since most of his
teammates are not playing due to their
injuries right before the game starts
his teachers arrive confirming that they
are willing to play with the team this
sport officially has no rules at all the
opposition retaliates but it is revealed
that the teachers already did all the
paperwork and are officially permitted
to play using many Kung Fu techniques
that they have mastered over the years
they managed to give the fireball a hard
time a lady teacher uses acupuncture
needles to stop the referee from
stopping the game for invalid reasons
another teacher uses an air control
technique to push the ball according to
His Wish meanwhile Fang scores several
baskets when Wang sees that his team is
losing he calls his henchmen to fight
the teachers they interrupt the game and
attack the rivals but are overpowered by
the Kung Fu experts the game is halted
because of the commotion when it
restarts a while later Lan and the
people who were injured in the last game
also rejoin Lee is surprised as to how
they recovered so soon Lan replies that
Kung Fu doesn't only defend but also
heals right now Fang's team is only one
basket away from winning the tournament
he throws the ball perfectly in the last
few seconds but the corrupt referee
stops it from going into the basket it
is clearly cheating but he claims that
his words are absolute when at his
lowest Fang remembers what his master
taught him a long time ago if one learns
the art of kung fu sincerely he can
eventually learn to turn back time he
recalls the moves the master made before
his death and mimics them a few seconds
later everything around Fang freezes and
the time goes back to five minutes
earlier if we learned anything from the
beginning of the movie it's that Fang is
now in an alternate timeline and in the
real one he's dead inside a block of ice
this time when he gets the ball he
doesn't throw it to the basket directly
but passes it to tang in the end he
scores before the referee can stop them
and the team wins the tournament a few
days later Fang is outside the uni
signing autographs for his fans right
then a woman comes looking for him and
reveals that his biological father is a
wealthy man Fang meets the guy and finds
out that years ago he was being chased
by a woman who wanted to kill him and
Fang hence to save Fang from her he left
the infant near the homeless man and
flew to another country over the years
he made a lot of money and wants Fang to
stay as his son now the Father and Son
reunite and walk away leaving Wang Lee
alone he had treated Fang like his own
son for the past couple of months which
makes Wang Lee sad that Fang didn't talk
to him before leaving when finally goes
to the restaurant his daughter works at
still disappointed in Fang suddenly Fang
appears and declares that Wang Lee is
his father for seeing the potential in a
no one like him the movie ends as they
decide to keep working together and earn
a lot of money subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching